vice just lighting Kansas City now first
off the Kansas City Chiefs let go
[Music]
[Laughter]
raining Jesus come on honestly thank you
so much guys
just don't don't let me put it on to run
out there then what is grandad doing
here so who got you into food where did
the weather the love of food convoys mom
dad honestly growing up but just started
liking food I started watching Food
Network trying to figure that stuff out
and then probably around you know my
teenage years went yeah I got old enough
that my parents trusted me in the
kitchen and yeah just went from there
and it's always been something that I
gravitate towards Oh quail eggs yes I
thought about your fingers and we just
smash it was supposed to be the surprise
at the end so all right I'm gonna put my
steak on first to get out seriously soon
and a beautiful the sear on there I love
the fact that you're rendering the back
down already to get more fat in there
I'm telling you man you've been watching
man all right coach told me you you were
good but you didn't say you with it good
creme fraiche as well look at you man
you have done this before my man I love
the fact you're making scrambled eggs
butter based over there
bring that baby over here big boy sounds
great by the way
yeah really yes excellent so we call
this one play day that's one place B
just so we can score we scored on
presentation temperature and taste as we
do medium-rare was what was dialed
agreed-upon before we start so for me
plate v1 with 27 points plate a came
over 26 and a half
dark that's just in at Kansas City and
sports trip to the Super Bowl in 50
I came from
[Applause]
[Music]
go chiefs go congratulations and come on
you can do this at the Super Bowl let's
go
[Music]
you